because of the allegations from the IRS
because of the whistleblowers and the
doj are Garland what he is saying and
what David Weiss are saying privately
are two different things right and if it
comes true what the IRS whistleblower is
saying we're going to start impeachment
inquiries on the Attorney General
McCarthy this morning related to the
conversation we just had Merrick Garland
s shouldn't just kind of blew it off
the president respects the Department of
Justice Independence he respects the
rule of law and that is what you're
going to see under this Administration
so I'm not going to speak uh to uh to
any any anything uh that is related to
that this is not uh the main priority of
American families
oh nothing to see here yeah because
you're not going to talk about the
economy we know that it's that's not the
main priority it's Dei that's the main
priority now just the doj spending years
covering up this massive Scandal for the
bidens
come on joining me now Congressman Byron
Donalds of the house oversight committee
Congressman
um
the the Garland testimony
and the Congressional role here given
that testimony we know that David Weiss
sent a letter to Jim Jordan on June 7th
that I think they're going to rely on
um and they have relied on saying I have
been granted ultimate authority over
this matter including responsibility for
deciding when or whether to file charges
and for making the decisions necessary
to preserve the Integrity of the
prosecution consistent with federal
regulations
and law
does that explain the inconsistency
between the prosecutor and Merrick
Garland here because it seems like there
was some cleanup done
uh good to be with you Laura it doesn't
actually explain it at all as far as I'm
concerned because we already know that
the IRS whistleblower uh testified that
they tried multiple times to bring
charges uh David Weiss tried to bring
charges in California that was blocked
by the Attorney General so in California
so if Mary Garland gave him free reign
why would the AG in California block
David Weiss from doing that why would
the AG block their wives from another
jurisdiction and why would Merrick
Garland block David Weiss from becoming
a special uh prosecutor because he
realized how explosive the information
he was looking into with respect to
Hunter Biden at the end of the day the
reason why he had all the jurisdiction
he needed in Delaware but nowhere else
is because he was being stopped by
Merrick Garland to do so and so we're
going to go through the process of
figuring out where all this actually
leads but in my view Merrick garland
does not have Clean Hands whatsoever
with this matter now Mueller's former
pit bull Weissman Andrew Weissman says
that having The Whistleblower
Congressman testify would be a huge
mistake for the GOP watch
there are whistleblowers they should
come forward and give actual testimony
under the U.S attorney could also give
testimony I suspect that the Republicans
don't want to do that because like many
of their hearings they blow up in their
face because they don't have a there
there
um so I think this is is Much Ado About
Nothing
Congressman much a deal about nothing
I don't even know what he's talking
about much to do about nothing we've
already proven that the Biden family set
up multiple accounts multiple llc's to
funnel money through to conceal money
you got Hunter Biden pleading uh
pleading guilty to a a misdemeanor tax
evasion issue two of them when the
reality is most Americans would actually
be charged with felony counts of tax
evasion you have the you have the
WhatsApp conversation where Hunter Biden
is saying I'm sitting next to my daddy
and we want our money Henry Zhao you
better give it up you have the
confidential FBI informant who's
basically saying that Joe Biden took
five million dollars from barisma to
shut down the prosecutor in Ukraine and
oh by the way Joe Biden brags that he
then you have the the in my view the
final thing every member of the Biden
family is getting money there is
accounts all over the place there's
money going all over the place there's
so talented to do about nothing come on
Congressman they have so much they have
a wide experience in the business world
you know mergers and Acquisitions taking
companies public consult they're so
brilliant that I mean people would pay
for their expertise Millions because
they're so more brilliant than any law
firm really it's ridiculous Congressman
great to see you tonight as always hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else